there was a time when the world was so  young  [Music]  there had not yet been a sunrise  but even then  there was  [Music]  to protect  dwarfs their minds  mend their fields of grain  but we our foots have each other  [Music]  we're safe  you have fought long enough galadriel  put up your sword  the enemy is still out there  the question now is where  it is over you have not seen what i've  seen i have seen my share  you have not seen  what i have seen  [Music]  darkness will march over the face of the  earth  it will be the end not just of our  people  but all  peoples  [Applause]  [Music]  i am sorry  but their time has come  [Music]  the past is with us all  the past is dead  we either move forward  or we die with it  this could be the beginning of a new era  away i must wander this  wandering day  [Music]  [Music]  you